I don't know how to do this it's gonna
take you a minute to pick up the pieces
Riverdale it's a town without a zip code
it is it's got a lot more going on than
you would think
[Music]
we're not letting us talk it down
without a fight
what does that say about us about
Riverdale whoa who is this guy the
variety show you remember that that was
great
daddy so much that
KJ what is one thing that fans might not
know about Luke that you've discovered
since working with him he only needs one
take what Luke is at work we move as we
were very fast but we have a good time
with that
you're a great kid arch I love all these
characters known him a long time and
these guys got a great take on him I
always like to have a beautiful woman on
my arm tonight I have to meanwhile I'm
having major deja vu I remember when
this was our lives times you know Luke
is I think he might be the nicest actor
I've ever worked with I mean he is so
nice he's so charming he's always the
person who notices if somebody doesn't
have a chair you know not just actors
but crew like he's just incredibly
observant always there always knows his
lines a complete professional and very
sweet thank you I never doubted him mom
for a second you should do it
your mother and I do you have a lot of
cool points from your kids about being
on Riverdale I have some of them some of
the cool points being with my daughter
what does she think have you brought her
to say no they haven't come to set but
they've been up and they've hung out
with the cast we only had dinner at
marks house and stuff like that and she
enjoys her time with them and it's
pretty good she had KJ tease each other
a good bit best time in my life all
right here we go what is on your
personal bucket list so you would like
to see Fred do I want to run the heavy
equipment you always see it sitting in
the background on the construction site
and I'm pretty good with all of the
pieces that we have I can drive the
track hoe and the dough's are in the
front I got all that stuff so I'd like
you to see Fred do some heavy equipment
we're burning daylight
let's get going I get it
I'm glad you're here though but some
advice man to man
you know these decisions that you're
making now son
they have consequences they go on to
form who you are and who you'll become
whatever you decide be confident enough
in it
that you don't have to lie
if you could give your younger self any
advice would you know you got to learn
it all on your own I really do believe
that you know life is experiencial you
got to get out there and you gotta try
it and you got to fail sometimes and to
get to any success you got to fail a few
times and so yeah he's gotta earn it
you're I was thinking you know I could
go with you we we could do this together
you know we can't do that i dint I was
your agent my father passed away I never
got to say this isn't goodbye dad do
damn right it's not see you soon yeah
you will
[Music]